you guys see this piece that Tyson just
made his first part on - that I wanted
to give it to Charlize the nicest guy in
the entire industry
[Music]
sup Tyson what's up ah that's your first
part man you like you're like a man of
experience now on this BMG Mori right
intellect when T 500 that's a 3 inch
diameter ants exhale for the titanium 8
inches long 8 inches long look at the
little life feeling work right there so
basically this is all one operation one
up we check the surface finish all right
so we're scribing across the surface and
the reading is 25.1 that's crazy right
have you have you actually like divert
it or polished it or done anything nope
that's how it is not a machine like bone
other machine look good looks good over
there with a black claw
[Music]
our wall matches your door and it
matches your shirt
it's like color-coordinate it just makes
the machine pop the machine just pops
your kill who does that it does that
[Music]
those are some big life tools right
there accidentally spun it around and it
cleared some oh man were you breathing
after that I had to step away for a
minute so can I see this thing spin
so look at the clearance
that's do that again do that again
oh that's scary that's a big tool that's
what I accidentally did that it cleared
so what kind what kind of cuts are you
taking right now seventy thousand steps
200-250 surface footage OD roughing
admittedly cool can you open the door a
source that's all you're talking about
yeah so this is the main OD tool using a
d NM g insert
and that's that so I can use undercuts
in the card and rough out as much as I
can
that's roughly rolling out
okay go down
take care of the deep down in there
we take the insert are you taking the
holder out or you know
after that I groove it
suck out a few burgers in here
this this one does a couple of them
that's the 125 wide insert I wrap out
some of this over here with the first
hole but it can't go down all the way so
it finishes up roughing here and then it
does the finish pass down here and it
also finishes this middle group right
here and this one's kind of neat because
you can put like different blades or
whatever you have different rivers you
can put in this
right after that I have this full radius
Ruger here
79,000
and that one
does this basically does this whole
center of this part here machine is so
dialed you can't even see the can't even
see the market there anyway
that next finished tool finishes as much
as the OD as a can here so it comes
across the top here over here and then
like I said it steps down over here and
finish this this back end
what do you think about those kind of
metal kingdoms 50 holders oh they're
great
I just popped take it out real quick pop
it back in I don't have to retouch it
off you just offset
the next tool i've got a face group here
so this holder here is actually the same
grooving holder of this guy here it was
about a different cartridge here for the
peace movement
and then that one just comes in
just doesn't as much as it can over here
and finishes the inside finishes
everything on the inside and that's it
though there's some deep grooves also
starts up here roughs out is all of this
and then it finishes as much as they can
finishes the top half and it can't quite
reach all the way to the bottom because
of the cross in the way so it stops
about right here
next tool then which is the upside-down
boring bar it's got a little bit of an
angle to it why is it upside though it's
so that I can use it as a movie
so this guy
and then that one just comes in and ruff
finishes roughing up the gear
in the finish
matches up blends in with the others
and after that we start milling and then
it's milling time so uses a single range
guy
does
we're going to do such crazy projects
that literally could blow people
and then we're gonna make it
but I promise you you're not gonna play
with these things
titanium
laughs the Lord
you know I mean like
so basically your house the mill going
is no it's great
so what your hot ass so you got a couple
different tools yeah so we got a pork
flute RPN mill to do the beads across a
bench
while on the side stepped down on the
other side awesome
and then face book then we had that long
end mill over there
found this super 4 million or now on
that spindle right there goes at 10,000
rpms and has some horsepower I had to
get some pointers from you on how to Mel
so yeah right afterwards we got the ball
mill that does
well thank you very much for talking
about the machine how about you show me
the controls again let's disco look at a
few things
so when you actually look at our
controls and what is your favorite thing
about them
and there so this only shows like what
comes up on the screen
[Music]
programs on come on autoload I have all
my program controls I got a little
stop-loss the lead
this what's relevant to that operation
is then if I go to the jogger mode
now I have all my rapid access control
that's great you don't have to worry
about like a whole bunch of buttons all
at once
you just have what
so now that you ran apart and now that
you ran all types of other tools now you
feel comfortable
going on to an even harder part after
this that way
you filled in them and killed it you
killed it
and then today you have all of these
guys trying to make parts for like
SpaceX
Aerojet
training boost easily nobody
thank you
that's a very first piece
I'm a machine right though
really impressed with the level of
programming and level work put into this
work
pretty incredible I'm I'm really excited
to get the first workpiece up that's it
and we love you met Charlie everybody
loves Charlie you know to me and there's
the man right there Tyson on the NLX
2500 TMG Mori your service guy came over
here like such as good things about
fights I know oh yeah one of the fastest
winners
I'm your dad but I'm also your boss and
I'm just telling you good job man
all right you did a great job
92 all right
Oh pull it up oh we're out
you